Going on. It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning podcast and just checking in on you.
This is not an official podcast.
This is where it just checking on you on a Thursday.
I see how your fucking work week is going at most the times. What?
You know the deal. I do it by myself. I lay around, I shoot the shit.
I say things. People hear things,
they think that it's about them and who is arisen in the White House?
Who the fuck knows? But every once in awhile I bring on a guest and when I do,
I don't just bring on any guests.
I bring on some of the most talented people out there and some of my great
friends and today this is no different.
I have the great Ben Bailey from cash cab. He's got a new special,
he's got a bunch of short films. He's got a new website,
he's got a bunch of shit he wants to talk about. Ben Bailey. What's up man?
How the fuck are you? I'm good dude.
Good to see you now have one was the last time I saw you?
It wasn't last November. Oh.
Might've been once since then.
But we had to have some sort of festival. Yeah. Maybe out here.
But you're talking to walking by to some social media tent.
You're talking about a Madison Square Garden? No,
November percent a year ago already. Yeah, it was, it was the shit,
the no longer Toyota comedy festival. Oh really? Is it done or is just,
isn't it just in New York, New York? No. Yeah.
Do you remember how many years when we were in New York?
I came to New York and like 95 I believe in, uh, I,
that's just a couple of years after me.
I started out here and then went back there. Oh, okay.
And we did like what we did like maybe four or 5,000 shows together.
We get something like that. I literally sat down one time,
and this is 15 years ago now, or maybe like 12 somewhere in there.
And I try to sort of have, you know,
add up some idea of how many standup shows I had done. What did you think?
I came up with 10,000 yeah, it was, you know, at least 10 years ago.
Probably more. And you count show is every time you go on. Yeah,
just any set I did anywhere. That's fair. Because anytime you go up,
God knows what the fucking happened.
It doesn't matter if it's four or five minutes. Yeah, somebody can still,
there's plenty of time. It's kept something thrown at you. I'm an awful, I,
you know something I remember I kept counting until about like 26 into 30 maybe
and then I just lost it.
But I remember though really you gotta keep a track of how many you had done?
Yeah, I probably did too. I don't even remember it, but I probably did too.
I was always jealous of people that did that. Cause A, I'm sorta like,
like I like, I hate stats and like trying to figure out what people,
where people are socially, but I love them in sports because they're,
they're like, they're kind of fact as far as like how many home runs you hit.
You know that that's like a ladder too.
It gives you some something to go up against. Yeah, but the, I,
I don't find a lot bullshit. Like, you know,
do it all we're doing when it's raining out and blah, blah blah. With,
with that, when you get to that shit, like I'm more into the,
how many yards did this guy throw? Four, how many did you run or whatever.
Stuff like that. Right. None had specific situations.
They do break it down a little too far. He like what? Yeah. Fuck.
It's the reason cause we have like nine 19 maybe 24 hour sports networks plus
Internet plus shit heads like me and all that. It's the whole thing.
It's just way too much information and a, what I was trying to get to was,
do you remember when the Toyota Comedy Festival first came around? Yeah.
It was the funniest shit ever.
It was just as they would say that it was the festival.
There was like nobody I ever met that was connected with it.
They would just hang a banner.
It was just a banner at the regular clubs and it was all the same regular
performers. There was no industry and it would just be, let them have asked.
He would leave on this weekend,
you have the Toyota comedy festival and we have Ben Bailey, Bill [inaudible],
Godfrey. He was on the same fucking people except it was a banner.
We used to have to, it took us like,
we were all so excited because we had nothing going on in our careers.
We were like, oh, I'm part of the festival.
And it took about three years before somebody finally just said, what,
what is this shit beyond [inaudible]? This is every,
this is a regular Wednesday. Right. And somehow though, that morphed into, uh,
an actual festival into the New York comedy festival. Right. Which is, I think,
you know, there's a lot of festivals, you know, out there,
but like New York City, you got to have a big comedy festival. You got it. Yeah,
I think so. I think it's great. I was actually, I,
I've been a part of it really. Uh,
but I'm supposed to be next year groundwork for the first nine years when it
was, that's right.
I was a part of it for the first nine and then I started booking people and I
missed the cut or some shit. I don't know. Yeah, you will meet both like, uh,
the New York underground comedy festival. I don't think I was a part of that.
I'm sure I submitted a VHS tape till it,
the joke was that it was so underground that,
and literally no one knew about it was, it sounded like surf reality.
It was the same thing. It was like, it was like a banner at a couple of clubs,
you know, and some guy, some guy had a bunch of money. It was like,
I'm going to have a festival, you know, that's it.
That's a great plane from La and stuff. And these guys would come in and like,
Yo, we're here for the festival and we're all like, Whoa,
what are you talking about? I'm sure we greeted them warmly,
homie fucking assholes. Well the last time,
well I guess sort of meandering my way towards was that Toyota of comedy
festival then morphed into the New York comedy festival and that's what that
they MSG Gig was last year. And as I mentioned,
amazing as I mentioned to you guys, you know,
obviously that was a nerve wracking gig and um, I just, you know,
I don't, I can't remember how the fuck came about.
Probably from doing the goddamn comedy jam or whatever. I was like, uh, right.
I, I've asked my agent, I was like, Hey, wait,
we paid to rent that thing all day. Right.
Considering 90% of the money is going to go right back to rent and that giant
fucking place. I go, yeah. I said,
can I like rent a drum kit first I was just going to rent a drum kit and just
jam with my, you know, my, my music by myself. Typical comedian,
totally isolated, but because of Josh had a miners and the goddamn comedy jams,
they like the people, they're like, we're going to be in town.
So I rented all this gear and um,
there was this running thing with me and Ben would for about eight years.
We were trying to get together and play music. You play drums.
I play at time and we're going to get together.
And every fucking time he'd come out here to la and it's like he's running
around, he's got meetings, he couldn't fucking make it.
And then I get to New York and he,
you're out in Jersey and that's just when you don't have a fucking car.
It's like, oh my God, I'm going to get on the path train, do,
we'll fucking anybody to come out chipsy cab. So finally,
like we're just like, um,
I'd come to town and we were going to jam and then that's when I, I,
we finally solidified it and I was going to drive out to your place so,
and you are all excited cause you, you made it [inaudible] built and everything.
I'm like, oh, we're finally going to play in it.
And he's all amped up telling me how great his fucking studio is.
And I was like, ah, I don't know man. I think I've got a better place.
And you're like, I got a better place. I'm like, motherfucker, what the fuck?
And I just said, I did it. Give you the answer. I think I told you it was MSG.
I said, well, I finally, I wrote back where like, I was like,
it must be someplace good. Yeah.
He's not just slamming my own studio that I built without having seen it yet.
He must have some good fucking thing. You and I know you cause up MSG.
I'm like monosodium glutamate
can be fucking Madison Square Garden Man. That's real.
I knew when I said I have a better place.
Your next text was going to come back and all capitals because Ben doesn't take
any shit from anybody and he's actually big enough to beat the fuck out of me
and about 20 other people. So He's, what the fuck? I totally insulted a studio.
So when you me in a better place. Yeah. So he ended up coming down and, and um,
as I mentioned before, is that my phone. Ah, Jesus Christ.
How can you be a flop?
It just makes it real.
It makes it real to the list and people feel like they're actually in the studio
witnessing how unprofessional this is.
How many of them like jumped up and looked around? I know cause I do have,
when the phone rings they're like, Oh, oh no, that's the standard one day.
Like if you're ever hiding in the closet and there's a serial killer walking
around, you know there's a chance when your phone rings,
he won't know what shoe he'll think it's him.
It's his phone for a second and maybe you can drop all of them and run up when
he, when he goes to look at it, you fucking smother him with your pj's. Oh,
it's a great scene in a film right there. Oh there you go.
Killer checks his own phone. He's like, God damn it. Yeah.
Could you want to do your life? Be Professional speaking to play in music is,
I have like the hearing damage that I have,
which is inevitable if you play or you do this fucking rate of the hearing
damage that I have is I actually got my hearing check. Like,
I still can hear everything,
but I have a little bit of displacement as to where it is.
Like it'll be to the right and I start going to the left and my wife just for
sting, man just laughs at me. Yeah. As long as it stays,
if discipline tickets from doing standup and like playing music and yeah,
haven't been, things happens all the time. I know. Oop.
From my opion Anthea says my ears are shot because what happens is,
is your ears get tired, you know, you keep turning up and turning up.
It's all about the duration. Right. You guys do like four hours a day and uh,
I try to be conscious of it, but like I fucked my ears up in the 80s.
One of my years I got that Tinnitus just rings at a real low level or from
really hung over it. But I mean, I don't have like,
like to the Pete Townsend level, but uh, so anyways, getting back to it.
So at Johnson, right, he had to quit. I know that was in DC. Right?
But not from the music, from race car driving. It's just like, what? Oh,
is that what it's from? Yeah, that's what they said. It wasn't, you know, he's,
it'd just been an ACDC all these years, like the loudest fucking band. But no,
that's not why he's ears are damages from driving race cars.
One of the first times I really fucked my ears up as I saw them on the, uh,
what was it, the hate secret tour? Oh No, I saw them. Uh,
I saw them at the Boston Garden Lights. I think Cinderella opened. No, no,
I saw him down in Providence. Was it different tour?
I saw them a bunch of times. Who made,
who hate seeker out during that whole period? I used to go see him in, uh,
I didn't have earplugs. And as loud as that was the fucking dude driving home,
he had the fucking thing turned all the way up to fucking 10.
I remember just like sitting in the back just taking it rather than ask him,
Hey, can you turn that down yet? You're making all of it.
I had like that German, Irish, just like, yeah, don't complain to complain.
Suffer in silence. It'll, it'll be over soon. That's what, anyway,
when you're at the back of a car and the guy's driving like a fucking maniac and
I'm, I'm like being polite. Yeah. I'm like,
I don't want to offend him by asking him to slow down or whatever.
I'd rather just risk my own death. Hey,
not trying to be that guy that tried to be that guy, but a, I'd like to live.
Yeah. I'd like to survive this ride.
I don't want to be in a halo at the end of this. But anyway,
so we finally ended up getting to play at Madison Square Garden,
which I think it was worth the fucking weight.
That was our Chinese democracy ain't dude. I gotta tell you, man,
I wouldn't change a thing. You fucking can play. Oh, you can really play a man.
I was really like, you don't tell him this is crazy. And I got to,
I got to show that to a, you know, a bunch of people. When I got to do a,
the tonight show, I showed it to a quest and Fallon and stuff.
I think I showed shorts. I showed it to them and they were just like, wow, man,
you should've given us, you know, Jimmy's all,
he should've given us the video we would have played. I was just like,
all right dude, it's not that good. Quite on that level.
I'd like to just show fun, Dude. It really was.
It really wasn't just going off and surreal day. Yeah. And I hit my,
my a then every, every so many people play to like my agent went out and played.
He almost didn't go ahead and twist his arm. Yeah. Yeah. Go up there.
I helped it drag them up there. I was like, come on dude,
we'll do a little wing or something. Michael O'Bryan, the,
he fucking ran up like, Hey Mike, you want it? He just ran right up.
He was great too, man. So, um, that was a fucking great day, dude.
And your show is awesome.
And I didn't know anything about efforts for family before that night. Oh,
that was what you guys played the preview of it.
That was the first time we felt like, Holy Shit, man, this is going to be all.
So I didn't even know. Yeah. So great.
Well we've got another 10 episodes of that coming out, but we're here.
We're here to, uh, promote your stuff. Let's start with your website. Um,
the Real Ben bailey.com that's you're relaunching your website or you just,
I'm relaunching it. It's been kind of just, you know,
very basic for a long time. And I was like, you know what,
it's time to just split start making my own stuff and putting it out directly to
people cause there's no reason to go and try and sell. You know,
like there's two short films on there that I made that I really love.
What's the one would Judah freelancer that you made a while ago?
I'm dying to see that, but it's funny. It's a,
it's called meet me at res and we made it like way back in like 2002 or
something or 2003 and then shut it down like crazy busy after that.
And it just sat there and now I'm just,
I just looked at him like I gotta put this thing out.
So it's just about two idiots meeting up for pizza at Ray's pizza in New York,
you know, but there's, there's a lot of raised pizzas, dude,
that you got a little busy at 14 years later. [inaudible] I'm like, all right,
let's put this thing out. And then, uh, what,
what happened during those 14 years? It was, you know,
he'd started doing all the movies. You did the cash cab thing.
That was so cool watching you guys like, uh, blowing up.
Like I felt like our generation kind of had like an even thing.
It was just like nobody knew who we were. And then all of a sudden,
like everybody started like, just got some inroads. I don't know what happened.
Yeah. Some people go into nowhere, you know? I mean,
shoot and I used to sit in his minivan at the end of the nights of stand up in
New York, it'd be like, man, this is brutal. We've got nothing. Yeah.
Got nothing going on. You know, dude,
I remember being in New York and then boom and I moved back from La the first
time I was out here and I had a, I lost my booking agent,
I had no manager,
I had no agent and I was incorporated as a business and I just cost me too much
money.
I got unincorporated instead of paying to be incorporated because I wasn't
making any money.
And I went all the way back to square one and I was living in that walkthrough
bedroom apartment with the guy who was on the lease.
And it was me and Bobby Kelly. We had a lot of fun,
but there was definitely nights.
It's probably good that I was living with Bobby cause we'd laugh until,
you know, you know, the late night in an iron man, take it easy.
But if I had to go home and just be with my own thoughts. That happened that,
yeah,
after he moved out and then I moved out and then there was that period about
2000 to 2004 where a, yeah,
there was a lot of tastes just waking up going like, uh, what am I doing?
What the fuck? I mean, dude, I had,
I mean from 2000 2004 I think somewhere in there I did get a half hour,
but there was like a thousand spread. The guy came to your half hour,
the comedy central one? Yeah, I think so.
There was like a good three year period there just being like, okay,
33 years old, 34 years, 35, you know, fuck,
this was not the plan. Am I going to be that? I thought it was okay. Yeah. Yeah,
it was. Um, yeah.
And then the whole AllSeen was coming up and that whole thing blew up and then
we would just, the fucking outcast. Totally. That was, that was rough man.
When the alternative comedy club scene developed and then just became this big
thing. You couldn't drag it. Industry person. Yeah. We're just in the,
in the mainstream clubs like oops,
you could no idea not going to move to those places. Yeah. Who, Oh man,
that was, those were a, Hey I'll tell you, those are rough ones, you know.
But we, you said that wrong changed. Yeah.
So you made that thing like 15 years ago once this movie that you have coming
out, cause I know you're going in the screening here, which is really cool.
This one's called blam badly, badly written action man. Yeah. Yeah. It's just,
you know, action movies, the action starts with,
they are badly written in a manner of speaking.
It's got a lot of quality in those, but, but they're,
but they're like one liners or like at least kind of clever, witty, you know,
even if they're over the top. Yeah, totally. So I was like,
I just thought, I thought of this character one day.
I can't remember what I was doing and where,
but I just like it be funny if you know,
so much of those movies now are built around those lines.
If when you finally get to the, you know, one of those lines, it's just awful.
Just no pay off. It's just no pay off at all. You know,
which is like an anti payoff really.
So it's kind of a crazy concept but it just sort of fell together like,
and how long are these movies? They're both about 10 minutes.
And this is like the type of stuff you're going to start putting on the real Ben
bailey.com just make it, yeah. Yeah.
I think that's a smart idea because I think those, those shorts,
they ended up turning into something they turn into movies and not,
that's one thing I've learned about this business.
This is just like when you make that decision like at this feels right,
I'm going to do this. So many people, they do it one,
two times and when Spielberg of Oprah doesn't want to interview you as some
shit, like well fuck this bitch tried. You just got to keep going.
Cause then when one of them hits,
then they go back to your whole library and you got all of that stuff and
they'll, something that will allow, will turn into it. But um,
I hope you're right about that dude. Hey,
how long have you been a lot into them?
[inaudible] is about 10 minutes and it's, and it's, uh,
it's badly written action man, which was originally a badly written action star.
Right. And in Lenny Marcus and I were working on writing,
throwing around ideas about it and he was abbreviating it when he wrote back to
be was Blas or whatever. Right. And that made me go like, oh, maybe,
maybe there's something in the acronym. Right. And then I was like, Oh,
if I make it badly written action man, then that's Blam.
And that's like a badly written sound effect. Oh yeah.
Know what I mean? It's like poem. Hey, you can just kind of fell together,
you know, when you feel like something's working. Yeah.
I had all these ideas and that one,
that little stuff like that just move to the front. So I just made it.
When you shoot that one, uh, in July. Oh, cool. Well there you go.
Now you've really stepped it up. One took you 12 years.
This one took you about 12 weeks. Yeah, you're totally right on a tear now.
Jesus Christ. But it's cool. DC Benny's in it and I love that. He's a Dante.
He's in it. He's a great actor. Decent dude. He's so good in this.
He's so funny. He's the evil villain in the in boy, man.
I'm going to watch this and this is going to be on a, it's in it.
Vecchio onus in it. A a riot. Masabi is in it savvy and Korean.
Holy Man. I was saying, dude, he'd be a perfect henchman. So yeah, it's not.
I'm a Salvia how we know him. He used to run the old Boston Comedy Club,
which is now you'd fucking wine tasting or wine. It's a wine bar. Yet.
I walked in there one night just,
I had them go in and look at it and there was all these, you know,
people in their twenties you know, prime of their fucking life.
Like we used to be and I just was going like, they're like, can I help you sir?
And I was just like this old man comedy club. And they were like, really?
And I was like, yeah, go.
I watched like a 20 year old Dave Chappelle right where that two top is.
And that was at first they didn't give a fuck til I dropped him.
And they were like, really? Oh they couldn't believe it.
And I was like all offended. Like,
how come you don't know what's important to me? Yeah, totally. I know. Yeah.
It's just like, well cause we moved on old man now I like,
or get the fuck outta here. That's everything for law. I'm fucking leaving.
I know 10 downstairs of that place is now the zinc bar that he used to be
called. The beacon cafe. Used to be the,
the bag it in the bag it in and we used to drink in there, put in hard,
I remember that kid with the glasses, the kid on the guitar,
he come down to fucking like whale like every Monday night even Colker Holy Shit
. That Guy David Coker. Yeah, I've still been in touch with him, man. He,
we did a soft for my last special coker and I wrote a song and did it and play
it at the end. Tacky that cash cab blues. Silly like, you know,
cash cab blues tune. Right. Cause I love Colker so much.
He's such a great musician. He really,
how long have you been playing by the way? A since I was 12. Yeah. You can tell.
12 years old. I, I uh,
the guy that live behind this English family moved in behind us.
This is six weeks. And uh, the old, the old, this guy,
the oldest son ships love. Hello show y'all.
It's this your garden. Uh, Oh, a guy. No, I was talking about that.
My last podcast. Like every fucking ingredients. Spice,
they always say differently. Yeah. So yeah,
there's a lot of little basil or Oregano Basil to my girlfriend.
You've met my girl, right? She's an Australian.
I have a new bit around one of those little things that, uh, that still come up,
these little differences between how they speak and how we speak. And she said,
uh, we talking about my daughter going, horse riding, right? I'm like,
horse riding. Like we say, horseback riding.
And then I'm like, why do we specify? Yeah,
horse riding actually makes a lot more sense.
They kind of get into only ever ride on one part of the horse. Horseback riding.
But you just said horse riding. Get off. It's neck. Yeah, horse neck.
So I have this whole bit about it, but there's so many little things like that.
But, so he's British guy. These British family moves in behind us.
The oldest brother is like, I'm like, I'm 11 what are the names again?
The Sedgwick's I just want to hear he said Andrew Sickly. Jones centric.
Just loyalty is with the urgency of, of that accident.
It's just fucking tremendous. I would listen. Not Fair. Is it the,
there's so much gravitas that comes with that accent.
It's just we can't fucking important everything, let's say. Yeah, sorry.
No, that's fine.
So the oldest brother is like twenties five or 26 and he's a sound engineer.
So he's got a studio in their attic. He builds a studio in their attic.
And he's working on doing sound mixing for some albums,
like some pretty big stuff like them. What was his name?
His name is Andrew Sedgwick. Okay.
Still is as far as I know,
but so I would go over there and annoy the shit out of this guy was just a
little kid who I was so curious about it all his equipment and stuff,
his studio and everything that he got fed up with me asking him a zillion
questions and he just put a guitar in my hand here, play with this.
So I started playing with it and you know, six months later I bought it.
I saved up my,
my paper route and I bought his uh oh you got paper too? Yeah, yeah.
Oh you say rod. I say Bro, look at that route. Route. [inaudible] wait,
which one did I say? You said route. I thought rob was Midwest. I don't,
we'll see. I have a little Midwest. I lived in Michigan when I was like,
when I was little. So I have this weird mix of accents. I live in the south too,
so I kind of don't matter. Something now my dad runs from the law. Oh,
he just, he's a killer. So how many times were you a the new kid in school? Uh,
for, I did it three times. It's brutal. Fucking brutal. Right.
I still remember the kids that were nice to me. Yeah.
I still remember when I moved the last time we moved.
Oh maybe the second time this kid Keith hadn't the first recess goes, hey man,
you want to play catch? And he had a tennis ball and you're like,
and I was just like, oh thank God. Cause he wasn't bad enough.
It was bad enough coming in like we were like Ford, it, we moved to the town.
We were like four days. Uh, we will,
it was already four days into the school year, right? Yeah.
Then we came and I had the very similar thing, man, and how they bring you in.
He's like, you don't just shit. Like I didn't just show up.
I didn't get on the bus or anything like that.
Like we went down to the principal's office because we were late and everything
and they were like, all right.
And they just walked us down and she just came walking and going, okay, class.
We have a new student. They're all looking at like,
I kind of like a energy my way through the last one I hung my coat up like, hey,
how are you? I made a lot of noise.
I went over and I sat down and then that's when I just sat down.
I felt out like cross my desk I felt was like right in the middle of the class.
I just felt everybody glancing me. I was like,
I have to sit down with my fucking orange hair. Like I know,
I know I don't like it either. Fuck off.
So it's brutal. Being the new kid is fucking hard. I was tall.
Like I was a big kid kind of at that age. In high school I wasn't that big.
Everyone sorta caught up with me and then I drew again later.
But when I was in fourth grade, I was one of the bigger kids.
So it seems like it'd be great,
but know that all the kids who were the bigger guys won,
I had to like fight them. Yeah.
I had to fight my way through first day of school. They,
people were choosing who I had to fight on the fucking playground. I'm like,
this is not lost. I always lost, I fought this kid.
I remember I thought this kid,
this is sort of kind of when I look about like it was sort of racist,
the way the teacher handled it.
He was the only black kid and for some reason we fought,
we fought like five racists in the road. He kept kicking my ass.
And finally I remember I was starting to win and he had these fucking work boots
on and then you just went like Bam, Bam, Bam like three times in my shin.
I was like crying right now, just sitting there crying.
I remember she fucking, uh, as we used to say back then,
balled him out is what he used to say. You get yelled at, she bald,
yelled at him and then came in and I was sitting there crying.
She came home and she like rubbed my head.
She even thought so you just got away with it but Kinda like maybe cause you
lost cause I was so pathetic. Or maybe I just looked like a little,
a little beat up Ron Howard. I Dunno what Ralph Mt for something there. Ginger.
Yeah, she was,
I actually thought about later like why was she comforting me?
We both got into it every fucking recess.
I was clearly not like trying to innocent to,
to get away from the kid. I didn't even know why we were fighting either.
Cause then we ended up being like friends.
It was just like that little kid shit.
And I still remember it somehow I slipped and fell and when I did during the
fight. Yeah. Yeah. And then he had this workbooks. I think he fell down too.
Maybe we should look with the heel of his boot tongue sticking out, you know,
little kids when they were really trying to make an effort and that was it.
Crying Dude, I had a bunch of cry.
Even if I won the fights when I was a kid. Oh. Cause just the emotions.
Just like, yeah,
I remember telling him I was at a birthday party,
we were playing street hockey and this one kid who played hockey was like really
good.
He kept lifting my stick and kept taking the puck and he was like fucking twice
my height. I got knocked on your stick up. Yeah. And I got so mad.
I turned around and I just started fighting him and he just,
he just kind of like, he like lean back and kind of like,
let me fucking get like three, four in like missing Kinda.
And then he just went blam and bass blasted me in the side of the head and I
fell down.
I started crying and I walked away and I just remember screaming the top of my
lungs and I was walk cause I used to cut through the woods and people were
yelling from the party to get to school. No, like no,
I'd cut to the woods to get to my friend's house where we were before we played
street hockey up. I was already into the woods and people were screaming, okay,
come on, I'll come back. And I was in the middle of was very south going, fuck,
I think his mother yelled one time and I just went home in the woods alone.
And this is the maturity of the other kid.
This is walking through the trail because they, yeah, it was always hot.
Oh, you're such a real moment. Yeah. Know, like I live the same thing.
And what was funny was I came home and I told my mother what happened and um,
it never dawned on her to call over there to drive me all that,
all that overly just getting involved with shit,
parenting that people have done it over the last like whatever since we were
kids. She just was like, wow. All right. Wow. When you get home. Yeah. Well,
you know, I have things to do or whatever. And then that was kind of it.
And I remember the next day, the maturity or the other kid was, um,
when we were on the bus,
I was like ignoring him and stuff and he just kind of yelled at, you know,
everybody stands up, you're to get off the bus. He Yell, Hey Bill,
let me talk to you. We get off the bus. And I was like, alright,
let me get off the bus. That's cool. Yeah, this is his fifth grade.
He usually just goes like, yeah, sorry about that. I was a guy man.
And it was fun. Yeah. I should've learned that lesson,
but I didn't cause I fucked that kid. Huh?
No, I should say his name. You remember his name? Yeah.
I don't want to say everybody's and I probably should've said it cause people
get all weird and shit. They're actually real people who are still alive. Yeah.
His first name was Tom. Put it that way. He's a tall fucking dude.
I told Tom Dude, I was way out of my fucking way class like, and he,
even the ass kicking was it gentlemanly as kicking. He just gave me one,
shut the fuck up. The sit down. Quiet little kid. Yeah.
There was no reason for me to fight you.
I was just mad because he was better than me. It was just,
it was really immature. Even for that age, I'm still ashamed of myself. So, um,
so anyway, so this guy ended up giving you a good time. That's for real.
That's really fucking cool. Yeah, it was so cool. Uh,
I guess she had paid for it. Well, I mean,
I could go over there and play it whenever, but at some point I was like,
I'm going to save up and buy it. I think I bought it for like 75 bucks.
Did he a he teach any chords or anything or was he no, no,
he just left me to it, you know, but then I like my girl, uh,
my sister's boyfriend was a guitar player and he was quite a bit older and like,
so he showed me some stuff and pretty soon I was like, you know,
I knew I could figure out some songs. I always had a decent ear.
I could pick stuff out and find it. But that was the only, that was,
unless you had the money to take lessons,
that was the only way to learn back then. I felt like lessons know, you know,
like kids today, the shit that they can see on youtube,
someone will just totally break the thing down, which is greatly everything.
Yeah. Which is great. And that's why there's so many monster players out there.
But like I would suggest if, you know, as they start to show it,
to sort of turn your back to the screen and see if you could just listen to what
he's doing and, and just, just so you always develop in Europe because I,
I wouldn't want to be that guy. Like, you know, couldn't figure it out. Like,
yeah. Well that's like literally in and out. Yeah. You know?
But I also think that, uh,
maybe one sort of downfall of all of everything being out there for anybody to
learn is you don't develop your own style of guitar, like,
or whatever it is. Right? Like I play guitar differently than most people,
I think because I, no one ever really taught me how to play.
I just started playing it. Right. So I have little,
little things that I do that are probably unique to me. At least.
I hope they are right. Some technique I would be like, actually that's, yeah,
that's wrong. You're holding your hand wrong or you know,
you should know it's still sounds good. But yeah, they were like, well,
but it's, this is what I do. So, you know, but I think music is like that,
you know, it's, it's, it's, it's your expression, whatever, whatever you do,
that's what you do. So yeah, it's a, it's definitely a, uh,
it's kind of a great thing for it. And it's also a weird thing because then I,
I, I definitely, there's always like, then there's like the top like fucking,
uh, it's just,
I feel like everybody's influenced now as is whatever subject it is.
The first page, the first three links, right.
Becomes like 90% of people's like consciousness.
Cause if you look at 'em I should probably, cause I even do that.
I should probably do want to go on youtube next time I go to look something up
to try. Just click to like, boy, what the fuck is on page three? Yeah.
Like I want to get into the age of 99. Yeah. What the Hell is on there?
The underground. Yeah. There's 100,000 pages to look at most things. Right.
100,000 hits on how to play, you know. Yeah. I played,
I played right before I came over here. I'm doing another one of those, uh,
the goddamn comedy jam. So I have another song. I got it. Nice.
I got to try to get together with one song or you can't say yet.
I don't want to ruin it cause it's cause it's part of the show and they get
there. But it's a, you know, I always stay pretty much, you know, 70s and 80s.
Um, I dress up like the drummer that I'm going to tell,
it's just completely ridiculous. Yeah. Cause they'd say what to do.
I want to do one of those with those guys. I gotta get,
I gotta connect with them cause they were like,
you should do and when you come out next, but now it's been a year. Yeah,
you'd kill it. That'd be so fun, Dude. I wonder if,
I don't know if Josh and those guys came up for the, uh,
the Toyota and now New York comedy festival. They were there.
I think they were in New York for that dude. I have so much fun with those guys.
Then one year I did Montreal,
the comedy festival just to come and I played with those guys three nights in a
row. Oh, it's just to do it. And then I, then I did a standup show,
but like the reason I was there was to do the music. Yeah. Because I played,
dude, I played for fucking like 20 years by myself.
Like it was so too. Same thing, man. But it was such like a, um,
like a kind of thing of like why I ended up becoming a comedian because I was so
introverted. And like if it didn't dawn on me until like the mid two thousands,
I started playing in the 80s, that was just like, hey,
kind of the reason for playing is to interact with other human beings.
To share it with people. Yeah. And then, uh,
thank God that that show came around and the first time I got to like,
well I sat in with a few other people,
but the first time I actually Kinda came out, people knew who the fuck I wasn't.
I'd sit down and was, it was a really like such a fun thing. So, um,
playing music live is like different than stand up obviously,
but it's so great. But I think it's just love it, man.
It's fun for us too because we're not in a band and we don't have to deal with
that because I know that a guys have met, they're actually in bands. It's like,
the big thing is how to keep it fun and be when it just starts becoming a job.
Like you've toured with other comedians,
you know when you're told with Comedians,
you're going to have the substance abuse guy. You gonna have the Pussy House,
the late Guy, the EGOMANIAC. Those are all the same guy. Oh,
excuse me, y'all. That's all Tony Woods selling.
Tony, tell him I'd have a couple of, we all have a couple of those. I'm one,
I'm a one or two of those guys from time to time. But yeah, I mean,
what two are you, would you say I'm late and uh, what were the other ones?
Substance Abuse. Uh, EGOMANIAC, Pussy Hound.
I would say I am a,
I'm definitely late and maybe at the touch of substance abuse. Um,
I'm substance abuse guy. Cigars drinking. Yeah. I can you,
I don't know if this makes me a fucked up or anything,
but like I know I could shut it off anytime I want to. I just don't want to,
what do you mean that the drinking or the, yeah, it's like, yeah, I could go.
I did it. I did it. I know you want a few years. I wanted like,
I did like a year and some change, you know, year in a couple of days.
I was just like, I just, I missed it. Yeah.
But it sounds like it like completely like ruins my a
ruined my, I'm like, I don't know. I mean I, I know when to do it.
I do it much, much more controlled than I used to. Like when I stopped,
I stopped cause I was like, Holy Shit, this is, I'm out of control here. Oh,
all right. I gotta I gotta lay off and regain my footing.
So that's five years I quit.
I think that's the difference between like maybe addicts and like fucked up
people like you and I where it's just like I can just,
I just want to get out of control. I was like, all right,
well I'm not going to do that for like a month, you know, stop for awhile,
you know, although this year, you know,
I kept saying that and it was never a month. It was always like three,
four days. I had a real stressful year this year.
Just a lot of stuff now it's just like career stuff, being busy,
being busy, being busy, and uh, all my free time kind of fucking, yeah.
Dissolved and uh, sitting there, you know, writing on a show, it's just,
you come home,
your brain is fried and I probably should have picked a better habit,
but it started to becoming, coming home and having a whiskey. Right.
And then if you came to, and then it became three,
and then my wife is finally like, ah, hey, you fucking booze bag.
What are you doing? Literally call me a boost bag. And then I, then I, uh, I,
I dialed it back and uh, for me it's just, it's, it's,
could you like laugh when she'd said that? Oh God, yeah. Yeah. You weren't like,
that's good. No, my wife is just hilarious. You know,
you've got all mad and be like, oh, wait a minute. I knew that I was,
I did that now. That would've been bad.
If that's your reaction and you need to think about yes, yes.
Standing there like, yeah, you're right. I need to rate it in. Sorry.
Then you're going, it's cool. Yeah.
I just had a couple of bottles hidden behind toilets and shit. It's totally a,
that's totally normal. No, I think,
I think everybody that kind of needs to have some little shit that's just there.
It's like, or like a little thing that you keep just for, you know,
you have to do it right. You know what I mean?
Like everybody's got maybe some secret little shit that's, oh,
there's whatever it is. I saw this guy one time, this old dude.
I'm going to move the Mike here. I'm sorry. I gotta lean back at some point.
Have bad posture. Um, I saw this one time I was staying at this hotel, right?
And it was this old dude standing there. All right.
And like every night like clockwork, cause I would finish the shows,
I'd come home, he come walking out was one of the hotels that you could die.
He had a little dog or whatever.
Nowadays everything's like a fucking therapy dog so he can get away with it.
It's a working dog and working. Don't, you're not supposed to ask. Yeah,
I asked the guy in the airport, he's like, you're not supposed to ask about it.
Well, I did. I'm like, yeah,
well if he didn't have a sweater that said working dog on it,
I wouldn't have fucking asked. Yeah. What's its job?
What's did it major in business? So sorry ahead. Um,
every night this guy would come out and he would eat, take out a little pouch.
It was tobacco by the way.
You take that out and he would roll his own cigarette and it was, I just saw it,
I was like,
this is this guy's whole ritual sat there and he would only smoke one and he
would just,
he would milk it and he would make it last for like a half hour and he would
just sit out there quietly, no phone, no iPad, no nothing.
And um, I remember seeing that going like, yeah, I get what that guy's doing.
Yeah. And I wish I had the time to do, uh,
to do a little more that we just have that,
that I think guys kind of need like alone time. I don't know how women are.
Women are a little more social, but I agree they probably need it too.
I have no idea. I shouldn't speak for them. I don't know.
My girl seems content to just be together and then you know,
and talk and chat about everything all the time. And sometimes I'm like,
why am I getting cranky and fucked up right now?
And like I just need to be by myself like I needed to.
I definitely need alone time.
I think that's why we got a million things going on. You know? We also are,
these careers are, are all consuming if you let them be right.
Cause we don't have an office, we don't punch a clock.
We don't show up at one time and then leave at another.
It's just always going on. Right. You have ideas, you have creative ideas,
you have schedule shit that you're keeping track of things going on.
Well I shot my special right on the 21st of October. I was like,
oh this year just shot a new one. Yeah. And I'm high. All,
all I gotta do is just fucking, you know, edit that thing,
look at it a couple times. Cause I know what I want and I'm like,
and I'm just fucking done, man. I'm that time to Christmas shop.
I'm going to fucking put my feet up, play some drums and blah, blah, blah, blah.
I mean, I don't know. I don't know what's happening. I'm fucking more, uh,
more busy than ever. And it's just like all of these, uh, I dunno.
I just, Eh, I don't know what editing is going to take a while, bro. Yeah.
But I've been able to do it this time where I sat through and, um,
I watched the whole fucking thing, which is something I is, you know,
it's brutal. It's you for a fucking hour and a half. It's hard.
And the longer as you watch it, you're like, it's not even funny anymore. Yeah.
You can't believe you're gonna get, yeah. It's like, oh my God, it's an old bit,
or, yeah, yeah. Fuck. But every time I go to do one, there's like a major,
like I say, you know, you donate a kidney. He just, I, there's always a chunk.
I'm like,
get that the fuck outta there and just go right to the end and then we're done.
And today I figured out what it was and it went from, uh,
you know why I felt a little bit too long to now be in like, oh fuck,
it's over already. Which is that sweet, sweet spot. Yeah, you don't,
you don't want to have it. Um, it's,
it's about 77 so that's about an hour, 15 hour and 16. But I mean, it was,
it was getting way, it was getting,
like when they took all the footage from both shows, it was like,
like an hour 30. And I'm like, all right, there's no way.
So we cut it down and then it was like one 29 and I'm like, but I like it,
but I like everything, but I'm just saying, yeah, I think you have to,
if you like release like a concert movie, I think it's gotta be, I,
I would think like 90 minutes if you people are gonna just, yeah.
And it's meant to be a feature. Uh, I just feel like Netflix,
if you're going to go on there and people are going to sit down and if you lucky
enough, if you lucky enough that are actually going to click on your shit,
it's just like we just gotta like you gotta go ACDC on them, you know,
where they don't play any ballads. You just gotta fucking just right through.
Yeah.
Unless you're like Chapelle which d Chappelle has that way where he can just
really fucking like bring it that like,
he's like just watching him do that opening monologue on, on SNL. I mean,
just like, yeah, the level of shit that he's doing effortlessly,
not even consciously the ups and downs, peaks and valleys in them,
the huge laughs and then the poignant moments and all of that.
It's just like that that was, you know,
I'd be happy if I could have done in an hour and a half. What the fuck?
He didn't like eight minutes, that clinic that he,
uh, that he put on. So, um, yeah, he's amazing.
Super talented guy, man. I always was. Yeah.
I always was when he was standing where someone's drinking as white Zinfandel
right now with the Boston comedy club is, Hey, so what did you,
uh, um, were you shocked about the, uh, election, uh,
results? I wasn't that shocked. Uh, I was,
we finally met somebody who called it. I knew somebody had to bet Trump.
I didn't bet Trump, I didn't want to bet Trump, but I did a tour.
I was on tour in a lot of southern states for, you know,
the month leading up to the election and nothing but Trump signs.
Right. I mean, that's all I saw. How much you can see a single Hillary song.
I saw hundreds of Trump signs and I was like, this,
this could, this might be real cold shit.
I never in a million years than I think, I thought Hillary was the main person.
At the end of the day, there's going to be, yeah. Until that tour. It was funny.
I did it. I did a Conan the day after the, uh, the election and like,
you know, I got so many people like fucking yelling at me thinking like,
how the fuck could you say this about Hillary?
How the fuck could you say about Trump like that?
You can't say anything about anybody.
I try to evenly trashed both of them and just say, Hey,
it'd be nice if people stop yelling at each other.
Somehow people missed all of that and they, they, you know,
I think especially the Hillary people,
cause they're so disappointed that they just needed somebody.
I got so much fucking shit from people and I actually had somebody just texted
me going like, hey man, I saw you on that. I go, and the guy was like,
it seemed like, you know, secretly voted for Trump. And then he wrote secretly,
secretly, twice. Yeah. And that was just like, yeah, like at,
no, I didn't vote for that guy. No, I didn't.
I didn't vote for either one of them. I couldn't stand them. I like Bernie.
Bernie was my fucking guy.
I felt like right after the election for the first time,
I felt like Bernie would've won. I was like, people really want to change.
You know, they don't, they don't know how to get,
and they kind of gave me the same old with Hillary. Yeah. And if the,
if I was like, Holy Shit, if Bernie had gotten the nomination,
he would probably be the president right now.
People think Joe Biden could have one. I think just like, like I don't,
I don't like familiarity breeds contempt. I mean, everybody's fucking filthy.
There was just something about like, I felt myself saying it,
like when I saw Jeb Bush and I saw Clinton, I like,
I just can't deal with another Bush or Clinton. It's such a stupid thing to say,
but I was just like, it's true. There's some truth to it because there are,
I want somebody else to lie to me now. I didn't want, I didn't want this guy.
I didn't want this guy, you know?
I'm not saying Bernie would have fucking solved everything,
but I will say all this shit that Trump's doing is fucking hilarious.
Where he's like, I'm going to do this. I want to do that.
I'm going to drain the swamp. It's like, dude, okay,
let's just say you actually go in there and you somehow do this.
How slow DC works. Like you're gonna fucking drain the swamp and then what?
Expose all these people and then they're all going to go to jail and like
they're going to be okay with this. Yeah, no,
I'm going to get all the illegal immigrants out of this country. You're,
you're going to do, how are you going to do that? You can do that. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm going to build a fucking wall from here. Take fucking California to Texas.
You really, you're gonna. You're going to do all of this through.
I think there are. There already is a wall for one, isn't there?
There's already a fence and a wall through a lot of it.
It's like at road can't stop people from coming in by blocking off 3% of the
border. It's a target. It's like they're coming in any way they could come in.
My thought he was going to go the whole face of the country,
he wasn't going to come in from all over the fucking place. Well, there is,
I actually think about that shit. It's like, um,
there does become the tipping point where you got too many fucking people. Yeah.
There is that, I mean, back in the day, yeah. We needed, you know,
we needed all we could get because of what we were doing, which was underhanded.
We, that's when America was great, but we needed to take all these yeah.
Get out there in the front lines and they would stuck them out west. Hey,
that's your land over there. Go over there and then provoke them into an attack.
Like what the whole fucking thing was shady. Um, yeah. From the beginning. Yeah.
It's not goes for elections. Well, you know, it's crazy.
They've been corrupted and fucked up since the beginning. Like I'm not gonna,
I'm not going to say the show, but I recently did a show, right. And, uh,
one of the comics went up and this person went and just trashed Donald Trump.
This is after, after the show, after actually the election.
I want the show after the show. They want up after the show, after the election,
right. It was like the full five days after whatever they went, right. And, uh,
went in hard on Trump, blah, blah, blah.
He's a sex offender and Anna and all this type of stuff.
And gradually the crowd started booming, right? Half the crowd,
half the crowd fucking booze.
So then the next person goes up who is a Trump supporter.
This person goes up and supports Trump and trashes Hillary.
Then the other half of the crowd started pulling them.
I've never seen like so divided dude. It's literally like,
it's like a great sec football game where they play in like a neutral site.
Like with Florida plays at Georgia and like,
it's half fucking bulldogs have gators. It's fucking insane. Like,
I've never liked that at the country's so completely divided that it's a little
scary. But the thing that I don't like is that now the p, you know,
whatever side you're on, where you're seeing the other side as your enemy,
right. When we're not supposed to be enemies, we're all supposed to,
we all live here together. That's ships, sail. Did I know that?
That's what I'm saying. That's what's shitty.
[inaudible] snooze came in and balanced out CNN by being just as ridiculously
far to the other side. I mean, those show, those,
those networks that are hilarious.
Like when on election night what I would do is I would just,
whoever was winning,
I would watch the other network just to watch some stuff into the sweat they
said, yeah, and just got no. I just, just for the comedy of it,
because I knew there was nothing, nothing. I mean,
I voted for who I wanted to vote for.
I knew this fucking state was going to go with Hillary Clinton. I mean,
that's a, that's a given.
The oceans vote for blue and everybody else in the middle of votes for red and
then it comes down to like fucking Ohio, Pennsylvania and Wisconsin.
Evidently North Carolina, which I, I didn't know about that,
but what I was happy was actually was up to date on all the propositions and
voted read them all mean.
My wife would read them for like days in front of me and like,
we're just laughing her ass off. You're like, you'd, we sit there like reading.
There'd be like a, you know,
do you not want them to drill for oil in the middle of your forehead?
And then here's the argument for, and you'd be like, wow,
that would probably lead to your death. There is no oil in there, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. And then it'd be like, the argument gets, actually,
it's the complete opposite. Drilling for oil would actually save this to sit.
Next thing you know, you're like, oh, maybe I should vote.
Like I didn't get anything out of those arguments.
And then we were just laughing. We did. You just eventually look at, well,
who supported this? It'd be like, if it was anything environmentally,
it's like Ed Begley Jr. All right, that guy's been riding a bike for 30 years.
Okay. If he's done with this, I'm going with Ed bag. His power,
his whole neighborhood by riding in on a hamster wheel. You know what's funny?
Hey Dude, do we know who, um, hi. What happened with the condoms in Porno?
Did that pass or no? Nice. Actually a thing. Yes.
Keep pouring out. Keep some jobs here and a in, in the valley, right?
So no, they don't have to work on them. No, no. I think that that was like,
if they do, they do. Okay. Oh, this is classic Americans.
We don't even know. All right, I'll look it up. We're going to look it up.
I thought it used to be that way. And now that they've taken a,
I had to wear condoms and then they were having a hard time. I think it was a,
you could not be further up that Mike. So you gotta make a quick point here.
Okay.
It didn't pass. So they don't have to wear condoms,
but they can't get permits right now. They're having a really hard time getting,
okay, so porno permits was saying that maybe it passed,
but they can't get permits now. Jesus Christ,
new things to vote on other than, uh, offices. We had to vote on, uh,
whether or not we want it to allow casinos in northern Jersey.
And what'd you say? I said No. Uh, which, and, and it didn't,
it was no as overwhelming. No,
they're not going to be able to put casinos in northern Jersey,
which is in my opinion, very good. Right? I don't hate casinos. Christie's,
but I don't think they should be everywhere.
What you say Chris Christie is fat and I cough, he's fat enough.
He doesn't mean to get in that that skim bag go on to Jersey. Mike's even more.
And the other one was like,
should we designate the money from tolls and fuel tax
into Trans public transportation?
Which is first question to before to begin with. First question is, well,
where's it going now? A well, anywhere else? I don't know where. I don't,
I really don't know where. But it was meant to be,
be allocated toward that a certain percentage of it initially.
And then that got changed somewhere along the line.
So ours was like voted changed it back was legalizing weed keeping illegal or
something like that. It was the condoms. It was like, should we repair?
There was one about building up schools and everything were initially you're
like, yeah, this is a good thing. And then, but the whole thing,
the whole proposition was written by these,
this group of people that are builders and Atlanta. Man,
I don't like that the contract is a right in this shit up.
So what's going on with this? Um, they, yeah,
a lot of interesting shit on yeah. That wasn't allowed. Yeah. No,
I can't remember how there was like, it was like at least another 12th.
There was so many, many a vote on every one of them. Yeah.
But what was great was we f we've figured out the best we could what it was and
God knows what is attached to all of that shit too. Right. You know what I mean?
And, uh, so I had all my answers before I went in there.
So what was taken everybody like, you know,
a good 20 minutes if you're reading it for the first fucking time. Um,
I had them all, so I would just look at the page. Yes. Was Up, no was down.
I would just look at my answer sheet and I'd be like up, down, down, up.
And I just, I just fucking blew through it. I was great.
It felt like I was cheating on a test. Um, well let me before we get out it,
we should, we gotta get the answer here? What's going on? It did not pass.
You know, it did not pass. It did not.
They can't get their permits to make porn. Yeah. Even that is calm.
Who's behind? Who's, who's a conservative behind that,
that wants to get porno out of the valley. Did,
did Tipper Gore moved to the valley recently. Remember her with the NPRC
one guy that wrote it up and if it passed,
he would have a job for the rest of his life.
Basically making sure there were condoms in porn. So he was
so one wait, one guy wrote in it. That does not sound real.
So like I could do that. Yeah.
He's the one guy who supplies the point it has to get,
it's got to get through some sort of fucking legislative horseshit right to then
get put on the ballot. So He's gotten money. Yeah. All right.
Cause I would say then the guy who said the rent is too damn high when he got
something done. Remember that guy in New York?
It's too damn rent is too damn high.
I hate it when like he kept getting laughs and kept hanging around and then like
one of those politicians like I agree with them,
the rent is too darn high.
I don't know how those politicians exist and that level of phony cartoons.
Yeah. Yeah. Algo was one of the most, was the one of the worst I saw.
And that was the thing I think about Trump that was amazing was watching him
just be a be himself, which a lot of people don't like who he was,
but he was being a person. A lot of people don't think a good person,
but like a candid, you can't, you can't accuse him of not being dude.
It was like there was sitting at the table,
but it was politicians and he was the guy running the table and no one could get
them. I couldn't fuck them. None. They could not figure out. They're like,
this guy doesn't care about anything. How do we pin him down?
And he didn't give a shit about what he says from one minute to the next.
He didn't care about the little care. He'd be like, oh, she's allowed to talk.
And I can tell great three against one, three guys, three guys, one.
But he said that it was, it was fucking cause Siri ticket, but it was brilliant.
Like do what he did. I mean,
I'm not happy that it certainly these fucking guys that he's putting together,
I joked to my last podcast, you know what he was talking about,
you gonna have change and everything and I was just going,
basically he's just doing the exact opposite. It's like fuller house.
You just bring it back. This old show,
I'll say it was like the expendable version of the expendables of Republicans.
It's just, dude, it's the whole thing to him was just a game.
It seems if you talk, if you see them interviewed, no, it's just like he,
he's basically like, oh I won and that was it. It doesn't matter how,
you know, it's just one, you don't have to worried about the summer.
And they're like, but you're going to,
you're doing all this stuff that you said you weren't gonna do. And he's like,
well who else is gonna do it? Basically it's like Marx brothers Shit.
Like you can't just say who else is going to do it? That's not an answer,
but it doesn't give a shit. He's like, this is why this is good.
It answers your getting so fuck you.
But the thing about the media is they had no followup cause they never dealt
with a guy like this who would just admit to, we had a, you know,
typical followup doesn't work because they call him out on it and he just says,
yeah, whatever, who cares? And it says something else.
Well [inaudible] back in the day when somebody would call,
when they would call a politician out,
they try to get out of it and they would stammer and then they would just keep,
you know,
hitting them with it until just the whole embarrassment of the situation.
The person would drop out, he just would admit to it and they had nothing.
Yeah. And they're like, well, when they said, oh, he's supposed to be bad,
I keep using this as the example that we use. You know,
you've said this about women, you've said that about women, you said this about.
And he goes, Nah. He goes,
I said that about Rosie O'Donnell and it got a huge laugh.
And then the female report, it goes like, no,
you've said that about other women too. And he just goes, hey,
you probably right. And that was over.
He made a joke and she couldn't even like,
or anybody in that panel couldn't have been like, you're probably right.
So you're saying you are sexist. Is that what you're saying?
Do you think that like, and,
but I still think because of what the fuck he represented,
he could've just been like, yes, I am sexist. Yeah,
I can't believe you're not sitting here and making me a pie or something.
They get Outta here and let the men handle it.
Clearly people were not put off by that,
but it's so hard to tell what's what's true and what isn't.
Anything you read about Hillary in the last three months or five months or
whatever, it could have been taken out of context. Absolutely.
Putting away to make her look, you know, show her in a certain light.
And same with Trump.
It'd be silly to assume that one side is doing it and one side the other is not.
No, they all are.
It's very difficult to tell what the fuck is real and what isn't. You know,
you know [inaudible] got their news from fucking Twitter guilty charge show me
too man. Me, Facebook, all of that. I, I, I'm,
you don't show me daily on Twitter, by the way. Real Ben Bailey,
the Real Ben Bailey B a I l e y.com. The Real Ben bailey.com.
I, um,
I was actually amazed the election night when they had the pictures of each
candidate and was finally one that the other side hadn't picked.
And I was just like, oh, look at Hillary. She looks like a nice person.
Donald me, it looks like a cool guy. Yeah. They look as Donald.
Donald was always like this, the scowl.
And he had like the things like that Rudy Giuliani picture that the left is
using where he looks like he's roaring. He just came up from the flames of hell.
That thing is fucking, you could, you could do that to anybody,
especially when you're there. Totally. And when you're that old, you know,
it's such an effort just to speak.
Your face is going to contort and they just have to do,
take a couple of pictures. You're gonna look like Satan. And then Hillary,
you always just had that crazy fucking smile and the Bible had been gone and
done really unflattering light. Like she looked like, you know, I'll do,
they did. [inaudible] they did everything they possibly could to both of them.
Mike Trump,
like his eyebrows by the end of the election were like beneath his eyes.
It's like, well frank, it shook the fact that he actually has one points out,
a point that he made repeatedly through the campaign,
which is that the whole system is fucked. It doesn't work. Right? Yeah.
But I will tell you all those people that think that he's somehow going to get
them out of their fucking hole is, that's ridiculous. No, you're not. It's,
they don't give it. It's on you. It's on you. When they try to act like these,
uh, these people are going to save you fucking ass. They're not. No, they can't.
No, and that's the uplifting message. If this podcast, it'd be worse, dude,
there's like, there's like a billion people,
literally a billion people in China that live in abject poverty. Oh, totally.
Are brainwashed into thinking that that's, you know, that's their place.
I don't know. It's a billion people. I know. It's like,
what the fuck? How would you even begin to try to, have you seen this?
Is the thing, tackle an issue like that? Have you seen no way to do it.
It's just that's how, that's how it is. Have you seen those cities?
Like they have a few cities over there that have so many fucking people.
Like it literally looks like there's a fire but it's just the polluted air.
It's just the area. It's just the air.
So like when they were having the Olympics over there at some point when they
were going to shoot something, you know, filming for the world to see,
they told everybody to like not drive or use any machinery or anything.
God knows what would happen to you if you did for like, like I don't know,
24 hours to three days or some shit.
And they just let all of that shit in the air just settle down onto the ground.
Cause that's, that's what it is. Yeah. Cause it's all like, even like out here,
like a lot of times people think they, the haze is smog but like hazy,
like smog is Brown. But haze is that clear thing.
And that haze is all the dust and all this shit that we're kicking up driving
around. Yeah. So everybody at bay, I think basically,
what's that new thing that kids are doing?
You act like a mannequin or some shit. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
They made like a billion people or half a billion people fucking do that.
And then people were just like, ah,
this is a great place to have people go swimming.
You guys just have to hold still until we're done with the hundred meter
backstroke. Well, get out of here dude. When um,
oh wait, there's a couple more things on there that I have any lecture,
any more movies or something like you do you know like the next one that you're
going to do? As far as the short film, I don't,
I think I might do another episode of [inaudible]. I like it. I like it a lot.
Uh, and it was really fun and like the idea was that another comic or you know,
actor friend of mine would be the be the villain, probably another comedian.
And so we just keep doing those. But I can definitely see that being a series,
a web series. It was a niche. Initially. There's going to be a web series,
but then I made the first one and I was like,
I dunno if I want to put all that into this every single time just on my own.
Right.
I might rather try some other stuff and say I want him to see what people like,
you know, it get some feedback once the stuff is out there and you go,
oh that leads to something. The next thing you know, you know,
you have something on you. I've got something on fucking Amazon or Netflix.
Yeah. Like you're walking down a red carpet. People yelling at Ben,
what are you wearing? What are you wearing? I'm like,
I don't know. And then they go back. Then they go back through all year and,
and uh, uh, uh, recently unearthed gym, meet at race,
made a face. And you sadly also have, uh, yeah,
for 12 years now it's a period film. Cause while actually was anyway,
I want to see it because I want to see like I, cause I'm,
I'm one of those guys that I, I love seeing New York and Oh, you'll love it.
Any era that it isn't now. Like I love seeing it in the nineties now.
I love seeing it in the 80s. I love seventies of this shit.
And then the sixties and fifties when it goes back is great. I love them.
Like I watch, I watch old fucking movies for that reason. Like sometimes I'll,
I'll watch an old movie and I'll see a guy driving down sunset and you just see
how spread out the buildings are and how, I mean the shooting,
so you don't know about the traffic. Uh,
but it's just like some of that stuff where it was just,
you could just see the hills and stuff. It's like, yeah,
that back then that's where they had like,
you want to go shoot a mountain lion and you're like walked out your backyard
and he's ready. He's just right down the road. Yeah. In, in La. So anyways,
I should say before we go, sorry.
I also have two podcasts shows that are going to be on this, on the new website.
Oh, cool. Uh, one of them is a storytelling show. Beautiful.
I remember DC Benny and I used to do that show urban myth. Yeah. Wait, what?
What venue did did that, was that,
I almost got to this earlier when we're talking about zinc bar,
because that was the original bank bar was on Houseton street. Yes.
And that's where we would do urban myth every Tuesday,
the new podcast I have is called tall, but true. It's a storytelling show.
It's been, it's pretty much urban myth. Oh, cool. Has a podcast.
So it's like the two of us tell a story and then a guest tells a story.
So love to have you do that. Call into that if you want. And then another one,
uh, and that'll all be on the real Ben bailey.com. Yeah.
And then one where my girl and I, it's called speaking of movies,
we watch a movie and then we just talk about the movie afterward a,
it goes around, which we love, which we did anyway. And then one day we're like,
we always have these great conversations after we watch a movie.
Let's just start recording them.
So can you recommend a movie that you've seen lately that you liked? Dude,
I watched, uh, you've probably seen it I'm way behind,
but I just watched Batman versus superman. I liked it. I've loved it, man.
You've already seen it all. Yeah, I thought it was great. I liked it.
I said that yesterday at a Benson's podcast.
Doug loves movies and everybody's like, what? They were like,
they thought it was awesome. I liked the uh,
sorry, but I liked the, uh, how the, the way they had f like the,
the government getting involved on me.
He just had this guy acting unilaterally and whatever the fuck that means,
you know, just,
just basically helping out who the fuck he wants and people claiming him and all
that. I was just going to hold accountable the arrows. Yeah.
That actually seemed like some shit that they would do and then demonize them
and all that. Like I always forget movies, the sat kind of song.
But that thing stuck out with me. I, I really liked that.
I thought it was great man. And it's, it's a, you know,
if you ever seen a watchman, remember that one? That's the same director, uh,
Zack Snyder, I think his name is. He made the watchman,
which is like super dark superhero movie based on this graphic novel,
which is awesome. You should check it out. You'd love it.
You're there called the comedian. Oh, cool. Superhero called the comedian.
He's like super dark.
The only thing I don't like about superman movies is it always comes down to the
Kryptonite. It's always, it's never, he never bangs the wrong girl.
It's you just know. Okay, wait,
when's the green chain getting wrapped around his neck? Yeah.
When's it going to happen? That's the only thing that can do it.
The only thing that he's, he's too powerful. That's the thing.
It almost gets a little boring. Well, well, Ben,
we finally got you on the podcast. I finally got the play jam with you, man.
It was fucking awesome and a continued success. Check out all things.
Ben Bailey at the Real Ben Bailey dot. Com.
You can also get there by going to three btb.net.
That's three baby t v. Dot com B as in baby, I should say.
Dot net.net. Sorry. Unfortunately it's dot. Yeah. Dot.
Mama's like some kids who have a site with funny videos that suck.
I shouldn't say that. That's me. I know. I know what you're saying,
but it's not mine. You went, you went for the joke. That three B tv.net.
All right.
I'm going to read a little bit of advertising and that's going to be it.
I hope you guys have a good weekend and I'll allow, see on Monday.
You fucking once I'll say
[inaudible].
Alright. Is he advertising? He Nia,
can you stop moving the shit around a track earlier?
We're all lose. This. A Newsweek reports.
The average American wastes 55 minutes a
day looking for things they own but can't find. Get the fuck Outta here.
55 minutes. I'm a dope.
Only look for 48 fuck Newsweek. No kidding.
Share a story of when you've lost something you needed. Oh,
I remember one time I was taking a dump, but I was like,
where's the toilet paper?
So I'm walking around with my fucking belt around my legs track or makes losing
things a thing of the past and I'll tell you how to get one for free in a
minute. Trackers, a coin size device that's locates, misplaced keys,
wallets, bags, computers, anything in seconds.
Just pair tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his precise locations with the tap of a button,
it's that easy. Lose your phone. Oh Shit. There it is.
Press a button on tracker and your phone rings even if it's when it's on silent.
Creepy tracker is finding over a million misplaced items each day.
Order yours and never lose anything. Again, listeners,
get a listeners, listeners to this show shit.
Get a free track or bravo with any order.
Go to the tracker.com and enter the Promo Code Burr.
The hardest single level f you'll ever have to find is their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code per for your free copy.
What? Free track. Bravo with any order. Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr. Hey,
where's the next read? Oh there it is. Thank you. Tracker, a Lyft,
you know about Lyft, right?
It's the app that gets you rides in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab if you try and lift. You know what I mean?
With Lyft, you just download the app. ProQuest the driver,
they show up in three and a half minutes on average. That's really fast.
In case you didn't know there,
every Lyft driver is fully vetted through their 10 point safety standard.
Have you ever killed anyone to d a jerk off when you're driving three,
right? They go through the whole thing. So you'd be safe,
including criminal and DMV background checks a,
you'll know you'll get around quickly and safely.
Why can I read tonight? Lyft drivers are rated after every ride.
It's only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting into a filthy card with some creepy dude.
Uh, with Lyft, you can tip in the app,
which obviously leads to happier drivers. I mean,
nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating from the passengers.
It's just better all around experience. What happens on that 10th one.
We'll leave that up. Bigger isn't always better.
I'm your fucking size queen Lyft isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing in the highest rated one.
I'm talking quality over quantity. You know where they're taking a shot at here.
It rhymes with scoober. Um, thanks to Lyft,
you've got an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bomb a ride and you never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting right,
getting rid of their cars and relying on Lyft to get around. And you know what?
I don't blame them. What if I didn't say that you wrote that? Well,
if you live in Nebraska, I think you're out of your fucking mind right now.
Lyft is offering our listeners a special deal. Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value.
You get those for free when you enter the Promo code bill bar a,
just download for free the Lyft app today and enter the Promo Code Belper and
the payment section. You'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each. That's up to a $30 value.
That's Promo Code Bill Bar. Once again, enter Promo Code Bill Burr.
I always stop this fucking thing. Press home to unlock. Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
All right. Yeah, I've got two more here. Oh, here we go. Boop, boop, boop me on
[inaudible]. Why did you vote for Trump? Do Do, do
[inaudible] America's taking a dump.
What we are supposed to fucking do. They got rid of Bernie
and they had that fucking Twat. All right.
Picture a world where putting it on on a new pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day. Think of what, think about it.
Underwear is the first thing you put on the last thing you take off.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Um, Yannis focuses solely on the,
on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever experienced.
You balls will thank you. Your Pussy will also say, you know, it wasn't bad.
My friends at me undies send me a pair of few,
a few pairs a while back and now I can't imagine wearing anything else.
Evidently it really makes each day that much better for the price of two
cocktails.
Me undies will deliver your favorite new pair of underwear right to your fucking
doorstep. Better,
better day guarantee you try them on if they're not the most comfortable
underwear, you know, do a couple of scissor kicks. Yeah, you're nuts.
Feel if they're not the best feeling undies you've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you keep your first pair for free.
Included in the prices this sweet touch of modal, modal,
a special fabric made of the best in class raw materials that are scientifically
proven to be three times softer than cotton.
I've been saying that for a year and the cotton people have not said Shit.
So unbelieving. That's true.
These Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on Mandy's website where you're on
joy free shipping in the U S and Canada. The rest of you can go fuck yourselves.
Um, and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order.
But you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr with beyond these that, uh,
with the Mi on these better day guarantee you have nothing to lose.
So don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] we're right now for 20% off your
first order. That's [inaudible] dot com slash burr and lastly,
but not leastly simply safe.
Ever find yourself almost all the way to work.
Or maybe you're out with your family and friends and you get that nagging
feeling, why did I marry this woman? No, not that negative feeling.
You start thinking, did I close that window? Did I lock the door?
You just don't know. It could drive you nuts. Well,
you don't have to worry about that anymore when you got simply safe home
security. Also, if you don't buy any nice shit in your house,
you wouldn't care either. But that's a different story.
It's a nice extra layer of protection to know.
Simply safe is they're simply safe, has an arsenal of senses to uh,
to protect your entire home and keep your family safe. Simply safe.
Got Rid of everything that makes home security such a pain.
There's no longterm contracts, no hidden fees. They won't gouge you.
It's 1499 a month. That's three times less than what other companies judge.
And here's some big news. Simply saved, just released. It's brand new,
high definition security camera. The camera is diff. This camera's different,
connects to your security system and sent your smartphone a video.
The second something happens at home. Hey honey,
look at that guy stealing all our shit.
You can see the stubble on the side of his face. This, this HD is incredible.
You can see everything that's going on so you won't have to wonder anymore.
Call to action. Okay. Checkout simply saves new cabbage day.
Just go to simply save bird.com right now.
That simply saved bird.com hi. Simply safe bird.com.
All right, that's it. Now I've got, once again, I gotta hit the home button.
I got to do the whole password. Fuck,
good. Staying and then
[inaudible],
hey, what's going on?
And still birth is the Monday morning podcast and a,
it's, it's
late in the day.
And I finally got to it and this is my fourth attempt at trying to do a good
one, get a good one now. But that line,
what movies that from fast times at Ridgemont High Mr hand, do you remember him?
Do you know the guy who played that?
He was in my favorite Martian and he took that gig back in the early sixties and
for so select 30 fucking years, every time somebody ran up to them they said,
hey, it's that fucking Martian guy.
And he hated life and he hated that fucking show.
And then he did that show movie.
Fast Times at Ridgemont high in one day the clouds parted and some young young
kid came walking up to him and said, hey Mr hand.
And evidently he was really excited. Isn't that a nice show? Business Story?
I don't know what the fuck that has to do with my podcast or this fucking bus
that is in front of me that is not moving. Go your bus.
You go merge, you've con. Um, anyways, uh,
you're new to my page on my website.
I do one of these every single week and people send me questions and I try to
answer them to the best of my ability.
I try not to say constant during the podcast,
but occasionally it's flips out when there's a broad boss driving two miles an
hour. What the fuck is wrong with me? I can't say words.
Lately I was working at Xannies in Nashville and I kept stumbling over words and
then I started thinking why I keep stumbling over these words.
And then I almost started stuttering on stage.
And speaking of which, if you came out to see me at xannies in Nashville,
Tennessee, I just want to say thank you very much.
And even though I just said thank you very much,
you might've sensed a little bit of anger underneath that.
And it has nothing to do with you guys.
It has to do with the fact that there aren't enough hours in the day today and
I'm fucking frustrated. And uh, I basically only have about 10,
15 minutes to do this podcast. And you know, usually,
usually I go on for about 45 minutes, but today, uh, whatever, half hour,
this is going to be like an EDP kinda like guns and roses that lies album,
except I'm not going to drop the n word, you know.
So slash if you're listening to this,
if you're one of the 14 people who listens to my podcast,
you're not going to feel awkward or after
I have to fucking explain yourself. Um,
I don't fucking know people. You know what? You know what? I got nothing.
I got nothing this week. I got nothing. Funny to say. I am fucking burnt out.
I just did back to back weeks on the road plus a college.
Do you want to hear them? You want to hear my a,
my week I was in a always in Washington DC.
Then I was in la and then I went to Colorado.
Then I flew to Indianapolis,
did the Bob and Tom Show, and I had a night off the night before.
And because my brain never shuts off, I'm like, well,
why the fuck would I just chill out in Indianapolis when I can drive four
fucking hours up to Detroit and go to a red wings game? And that's what I did,
except I thought it was only a two hour drive and it turned out it was a fucking
four hour drive, four and a half actually. And I went up,
there was Redwings penguins,
which turned out to be one of the games of the year,
but I had to leave before the third period ended.
And I missed the penguins come back and went and over time.
But I still got to go to that arena. And, uh,
I couldn't believe how small it was. You know, there was no upper deck.
It just kind of went straight up. You know, it was kind of an, I don't know,
an old school building and like in 1975 kind of way. But, uh,
I was really cool and the fans were awesome. And uh, you know,
I don't like go into that expansion shit and I don't like fair weather fans and
that's choice. Got Good fans. And there were a lot of Pittsburgh penguin fans.
They're talking a lot of shit even when they were down for two or to two
periods. And I missed them all talking shit when they came back and one seven,
six and fucking over time.
And where was driving by fucking corn field in the middle of Indiana, Bob.
And
so my brain right now is frazzled and um,
you know, you might wonder, uh, what the fuck is wrong with bill and, uh,
you know, I don't have any answers driving a hybrid.
I just drank three quarters of a Sam Adams Beer, one of their seasonal brews.
And I'm on my way to a writers meeting because I have to go write some sketches
for something that I'm shooting and I'm exhausted.
This is one of these times when I just wanna sleep for fucking nine,
10 hours and wake up the next day and just stare at the fucking wall.
But I can't because I have to do this.
I have to somehow put my voice into a sketch, which is not an easy thing to do.
I find it's very hard for me to write sketches because I write very set up,
punch, set up, punch.
There's not a lot of layers that mental left model left turns, you know,
it's just like my act.
There's a lot of screaming and a the f word so long you have to figure out how
to do that. And we're at a red light,
so I think it's time for a podcast question. Look at this.
This is just like the cash cap. Uh, okay. Bill. Question number one.
Have you ever been asked to write material for another comedian?
First of all, look at this fucking guy riding down the street with a bicycle.
I hate when people do that.
They put a reflector on their back and then all of a sudden they just,
they feel like they're like a, this sorta like a,
a motorcycle on some level.
They start riding with traffic like the Kevin Bacon and quicksilver, you know,
nothing makes me want to lean over and open my passenger door
and commit vehicular manslaughter like some fucking turn your life.
Somebody didn't have the lights on. Um, like that. Do you know what?
I don't know what the fuck was I taught? What was the question?
Have I ever been asked to write material for another comedian? Ah, yes,
yes. I have. I have a written for a,
I wrote for one roast is Shaquille O'Neal roast and I got to admit,
you know, at first I started writing the jokes and I was like,
I don't want to write jokes from another comedian.
I want to write them for me and I want to be able to say them.
So I get the laugh.
But then I realize what's cool about a roast is you're not at work like writing
for Comedians Act,
whether then going to go on HBO and kill with some joke and get credit for,
um, it's, it's a very specific thing.
It's not like I have a chunk of material about Shaquille O'Neal,
so what do I care? And I wrote it and dome evidently went really well.
People in the writers room, I guess liked it.
And I got a real kick out of it and a, I got one joke on the air
and I believe that joke was, uh,
something about watching Shaquille O'Neal play basketball was like watching a
retard, something along those lines,
something along the lines of that. He was just such a big dude. You know,
he's such a big fucking dude that even when he dunks the ball,
it doesn't look good. He looks like a fat kid, Dunkin,
a ball and like a nerf hoop set. And that was basically, that was basically it.
I went the cheap route. I use retard as a reference out, so I'm not proud of it,
but it got on the air. All right, here's another one.
Do you agree that the reason main TV shows are abruptly canceled?
The reason many TV shows are properly canceled is due to the media's attempt to
control what we watch, such as reality TV. Okay.
Um, the media, his attempt is if the entire media is working together,
um, if you're in the conspiracy theory,
I would work a little higher up the ladder and try to see who owns media in this
country. And you'd be surprised. It's not that many people. So,
uh, I dunno.
I don't think reality TV is an attempt to keep for them to control what we
watch. I just think it's really cheap and it's, uh,
it's something mesmerizing about watching 10 losers in a house,
talk shit about each other. As much as I make fun of it.
Does this guy just fucking bump into me with the fuck is wrong with you?
You fucking idiot. I just fucking rear ended me.
Hang on a second.
Fucking do this. I'll fuck away. He just did that
[inaudible]
quite a gut. I think some guy just literally tapped my bumper.
Hang on a sec.
You know what?
This would be great if we get to a fucking red light cause I know we didn't hit
it hard enough. Hold on, hold on a second.
[inaudible]
bump into me. Hang on a sec.
Did you just bumped into me? You didn't. Okay.
I don't know if it was my car or not.
I was wondering why you had such a nonchalant look on your face.
I'm like he's saying all right. I'm just making sure. Alright. Alright,
sorry about that. Okay. All right.
Okay, so anyways, let me know. You didn't bump into me.
I think my car just had like a hiccup but it literally felt like somebody just
tapped my phone and I looked in the rear view mirror.
This guy was right on my fucking ass. You guys almost heard in la moment
what is I fought him. I want to fuck, fuck.
And if the I have enough speaker phone do it,
then they could have used my podcast in court.
Then I finally would have got past like 50 fucking listeners. God Damn it.
That was, that was a moment right there. That was a moment that almost happened.
Chris. Stupid question. Did you just pull up into me? Ah, no, I, oh, okay.
Jesus. Can you believe I'm not a private investigator with that?
So that sort of fucking police work. All right. So anyways,
anyway, Shit. I gotta wrap this podcast up cause I'm at where the fuck I'm at.
So this guy BIM writers thing that I'm doing, but you gotta admit, you know,
that was pretty exciting that for a second. Um, all right, let's,
let's try to blow through some of these more, some more of these questions. Oh,
before I get off the phone,
thanks to everybody who came up to see me that xannies in Nashville,
Tennessee and had an awesome time and literally tons more people showed up since
the last time. It's really made me feel good that, you know,
people actually saw my special, they liked it and it made them want to come out.
And uh, I'm really psyched about that. And I know I've been telling you guys,
I'm putting the dates up for 2009 they're definitely getting up this week.
I talked to my booker and uh, they're supposed to be emailing me something.
So I'll get the dates up, up on my website, up on my mind space page.
Please come out to see me and you'll watch me put together my next special that
hopefully I will take this summer coming summer. So anyways,
here's a long question about corporate America. Hey Bill,
let me tell you why I F in hate corporate America,
especially Verizon exclamation point.
They sold me a blackberry that recently for the fifth time,
the keyboard wouldn't work,
couldn't make or answer calls and couldn't do anything.
Each time it would happen, I'd go to Verizon, they would fix it for me.
But the last time, a few weeks ago,
a buddy of mine in the army was costing to the day before he shipped off to Iraq
and I was unable to answer the call. Jesus, that sounds like a lifetime movie.
I guess a little phone, I need to say goodbye.
So I went to Verizon furiously as you should have demanding an explanation on
why they sold me such a shitty phone.
They told me that they could do was replace it with the same model phone in
which my response was all you'd be doing is giving me a shiny year piece of
shit. God bless you. God bless you.
That's exactly what you should have said and they should have taken the phone
and buried inside of his head and blamed him for that design as if he designed
it all right. Leading me.
And this basically led him to sign up with a t and t and now Verizon wants to
charge me with $125 early termination fee.
I've been arguing my case with them on the phone trying to explain to them that
if I still had Verizon I wouldn't be able to make this phone call.
They kept telling me that they understand why I am except upset and which my
response was great.
So if you understand why you still ask for my money and basically there is no
way that I'm going to buckle and give it in to them. Good, good for you.
I keep calling them disputing them.
I'll keep calling them the student up for two years if I have to.
To me it's a matter of principle because what pisses me off is how these
corporations are allowed to conduct business. You know,
I don't even need the rest of the three. The rest is exactly exactly that.
They're bigger than you and they have more money than you and they can wait you
out and then they can send you shit to a collection agency cause you're the
little guy and they know that you're not going to do that.
This is what you want to do. You want to, you got to do that old school thing.
Just go.
I want it to speak to a manager and you keep going up the ladder asking to speak
to somebody, bumped them, get everybody's name,
keep using words like ridiculous and outrageous.
Like this is ridiculous.
This is outrageous and a just do it the way like an old lady would and just,
just don't get off the phone. Don't ever curse. If you never curse,
then they can't. Uh,
they can't hang up on you. I'm full of Shit. I don't know what to do.
You know what? Go burn down their fucking building or something.
But I'm sorry man, I really didn't answer that question well, but, uh,
I gotta go in and do this meeting, so whatever.
Thanks for listening to the Monday morning podcast. I know this was real short,
but hey,
we had a nice yelling match with a potential yelling match with another person
in the car, which turned out to be friendly.
How bad did you guys want that to escalate into violence? You know, you did.
Then you could have heard me get my ass kicked.
Like I just rolled down the window like I've ever taken a karate class.
It was fucking ridiculous. But fortunately, shit didn't go down that way.
So anyways, it was very short, very exciting. TJ Hooker,
episode of the Monday morning podcast. Keep listening.
Please keep sending the questions and, uh, that is that.
God bless all you have.
Please come and see me at Caroline's in New York City the first week in
December. And, uh, that is it.
And I apologize to the guy who I thought hit my car, but really didn't,
if he's a podcast listener. All right, dude. That's it. All right guys.
Take it easy. Bye. Alright. Take it easy. Bye Bye. Take it easy. Bye Bye.
Take it easy. Bye.